the NFL is at a tough couple of years
2013 was the year of the head injury but
everyone's already forgotten about that
due to early onset irony and up until
this week the number one issue plaguing
the NFL was domestic violence that was
until deflated gate put the NFL's balls
well and truly on the table balls balls
balls fine fine forget domestic violence
we'll talk about balls what is it about
this game that makes it the best game in
the world strategy war first was the
Super Bowl so it's the game of all games
the game everyone in the NFL strives to
play in this game in the world I'm
hearing deflategate but I don't
understand what it means well is
basically that the ball had pressure
taken from it taking the air out of the
football it's a controversy about balls
a lot of people are saying the problem
with the flight gate is the ball sack
whether the ball sack was left
unattended people should be looking at
the ball sack all day Bubba up I was
wondering if you could feel my balls you
have nice ball are you like Lance
Armstrong you only have one this feels
very inflated huh I think the color
would work I can't get much of a grip I
think that's about 13 right there you
got hard balls I brought a present for
Bill Belichick or present what I've got
him a nice present I wonder if he'd like
it I got him a ball pump he may use this
part right right he may tell you to keep
that part okay
how you gonna bump your balls you don't
have it i'm dan from australia I've got
one gift for you a ball pump in case you
needed this afternoon what kind of balls
you need to play this game our balls
like steel balls not blue but still what
kind of size balls do you need to have
to say run a 9.5 billion dollar
enterprise but still call yourself a
non-profit what who does that d NFL
order a non-profit yeah sounds like a
conspiracy what size balls you need to
say I don't know drag your fiance out of
the lift um you probably small balls how
big a bull's you need to have to like
besh your cape with a stick I think I
mean you probably don't need balls for
that you definitely need a stick though
I mean Adrian Peterson it was a switch
as they refer to it as a switch which is
well that's a stick that to be honest
that's a stick well there you have it to
open up a dialogue about the big
problems of the NFL just required some
balls balls the ingredients of a great
package big bowl big extra box
Australians aren't racist but from 1901
to 1970 we had a series of laws
restricting the immigration of people
darker than the color unwashed beige